well for a magnificent view of nature's
greatest power display there's been a
lot of volcanic activity in 2018 Mount
Mayon and the Philippines erupted in
January it continued for over a month in
February Mount Sinabung erupted in
Indonesia here's the ash cloud as seen
from space and in June an eruption in
Guatemala killed more than 100 people
turns out this is pretty normal on
average there are 10 to 20 volcanoes
erupting around the world at any given
time when you look at these on a map and
add volcanoes that are not currently
erupting you'll start to see a pattern
most are concentrated here along the
edges of the Pacific Ocean
this region is known as the Ring of Fire
a stretch of hundreds of volcanoes
spanning 40,000 kilometers it's also
where most of the earthquakes and
tsunamis in the world take place this
year alone the region saw four eruptions
and five of the world's biggest
earthquakes the Ring of Fire is where
some of history's most devastating
natural disasters have happened and will
continue to happen
[Music]
still some volcanoes around the world
various places do you know where they
are here's a match you could combine
some volcanoes have terrorized people
for centuries in the 1800's explorers
and scientists started grouping them
together take a look at this map from
1852 it has the volcanic series of
Australasia and the volcanic series of
Japan and Kamchatka and Russia in fact
the whole Ring of Fire is marked here
scientists recognize the belt of
activity but it would take another
hundred years until they agreed on what
caused it volcano let's see what you and
I are gonna talk about today is the
world under our feet by the 1960s most
scientists concluded the Earth's surface
is made up of a series of tectonic
plates that slowly moved into and apart
from each other take a look at the
plates that make up the Pacific now look
at where the eruptions and earthquakes
occur the Ring of Fire is the result of
these plates crashing into each other
one in Japan is right Fujiyama right
there's some others in the in the South
Pacific part of the world that's right
there's a blue Mexico the plates in the
Pacific are moving faster than other
plates around the world adding stress or
the plates interact this plate is moving
Northwest crashing into the North
American plate which explains all the
volcanoes here over in California the
Pacific plate is grinding past the North
American plate where they meet is called
the San Andreas Fault the movement
causes thousands of earthquakes a year a
few of them are even large enough to
cause serious damage like the San
Francisco Oakland earthquake in 1989
which killed 63 people and injured
nearly 4,000 all these plate
interactions are independent from each
other but when grouped together they
make up the most seismically active
region in the world little while ago an
island blew up
oh yes appear because of a volcano here
the problem with the Ring of Fire
is that geologists can't accurately
predict when a volcano is going to erupt
or an earthquake will shake the ground
they can monitor tremors gas emissions
and temperature changes around the
volcano to estimate when it might erupt
but they can't be sure of the exact
timing or the severity and those
predictions get even weaker with
earthquakes which aren't preceded by any
warning signs so we can't even see them
coming one way scientists forecast the
future of these phenomena is by looking
at the past take New Zealand for example
earthquakes have occurred on this fault
line every 500 to 1,000 years there was
a massive quake over 800 years ago and
another one around the 500 mark so
scientists now believe a new zealand is
due for a mega quake
over here in California there's a 72%
chance of a major earthquake along the
northern section of the San Andreas
Fault Line in the next 30 years parts of
Japan have a 25% chance of a big quake
and Seattle could see one in the next 50
years
that could impact seven million people
in fact many countries along the Ring of
Fire will continue to be at risk for the
foreseeable future they can't get out of
harm's way but there is something they
can do about it in 2011 an earthquake
and a following tsunami killed 15,000
people and caused 300 billion dollars in
damages in Japan but those numbers could
have been a lot higher see Japan
requires buildings be constructed with
anti earthquake designs like the one in
this video
and it has an early warning system that
stopped high-speed trains factory lines
and sent countrywide text alerts a full
minute before the tremor hit while
Japan's precautions didn't prevent the
disaster they did save countless lives
the problem is not every country in the
Ring of Fire is like Japan most of these
countries have some form of anti
earthquake building code but the quality
and implementation of these codes varies
and none of these countries have early
warning systems for earthquakes in
developing countries funding these
projects can be a problem but even
richer countries aren't taking the risk
seriously enough California Oregon
Washington some of the most vulnerable
states in the u.s. still don't have a
public early warning system in place
because volcanoes and earthquakes
continue to be unpredictable threats
governments tend to treat them as a low
priority and that's what makes the Ring
of Fire even more dangerous we know for
certain that there will be more natural
disasters along this belt what we don't
know is if we'll be prepared for them
tinker studies will surely improve the
clarity with which fire to view the
interior of the earth and will help
people accommodate their activities to
be powerful sometimes destructive often
beneficial always fascinating neighbors
[Music]